the jurogan experience it's just
the the idea of pulling up at a yacht is
the end it's the opposite
of what everybody tells you about
fighting right fighting you have to stay
hungry
like stay humble you know like like you
know rocky iii style
yeah like you don't you don't pull up in
a [ __ ] yacht
and if you but if you do the only person
who's been able to do
like that is floyd mayweather he's the
only guy
who's been able to just be balling out
of control
constantly flashing money million dollar
watches
you know a fleet of super expensive cars
and still [ __ ] everybody up he does
he's the only guy yeah
literally the only other guys besides
like jimmy connor who's really
adrian broner but he's he's he just won
i think
he won he disputed decision but he seems
to be
more concerned with having fun and being
crazy
the thing about floyd is he never lost
his discipline like floyd's discipline
was uh
undeniable right but through that ball
in knights he never
i don't think he was doing drugs or
drinking you know he kept his
pretty floyd would famously run home
from the nightclub
so he would go out in vegas he'd be
partying it looked like he's party he's
drinking water
and then he would have his driver drive
and with his [ __ ] pants on with jeans
on he would jog home
and the dude was always training always
training never got out of shape
dude the jock home and jeans isn't the
torture the torture is sitting around a
bunch of drunk people drinking water
in a club i jog home all night
rather than that right yeah yeah it's an
interesting thing though the the keeping
your motivation
as you reach a certain level of fame and
success
because that's a lot of the motivation
for fighters is to
to one day be that champion one day have
that money where your family's going to
be taken care of for life
you don't have to worry anymore do you
hit that spot like and then what keeps
you going
yeah how do you remain a student in that
spot yeah there's the famous quote that
it's hard to wake up and and
run the miles when you're sleeping in
silk pajamas i forget what boxers said
that but
yeah it's got to be true you know um
what unless you just keep setting goals
maybe he's trying to
to do something that's never been done
maybe that's the driving factor now
you know because a lot of guys money
might be the driving factor but once you
get the money maybe you set it up to try
to
leave legendary things behind like well
the thing about floyd is he spends so
much money
maybe that maybe money's still the
motivation because he's just
always about to go broke because he's
just he spends like a [ __ ] maniac i
would like to think even though he's
spending like that
he's made some great investments and
yeah i'd like to think that too but i
bet it's not the case
yeah yeah definitely spend a lot of
money
but he's made so much man over a billion
right isn't that crazy over a billion
over a billion dollars in fighting a
billion a
with a b and now he's about to fight
logan paul
in a boxing match in japan but
apparently they postponed that right
i thought it was a different fight in
japan no i think it's logan paul
right it is yeah no it's logan paul they
postponed it though because they weren't
they didn't have enough pay-per-view
interest right is that the jamie you
know the
not according to them but probably the
cover uh
i mean uh mayweather side yeah a new
date's coming soon
yeah whatever that means i mean he's
he's fighting 200 pounders
i mean obviously logan paul's not a real
professional boxer and in terms of like
certainly not in the caliber of floyd
mayweather but
it's a big [ __ ] dude yeah huge
because floyd's not a big guy
no you know i've never seen uh the other
guy in person i don't know how big he is
i met him he's a big [ __ ] yeah
yeah he's big his skills pay the bills
man
i guess so he doesn't give a [ __ ] man
well he also fought tension nazukawa
the the little tiny dude in japan which
was ridiculous and that guy fights at
like 126.
yeah i was surprised how that went i
i thought floyd was gonna beat him but i
thought it would be a little bit more
happening than that that was
i floyd didn't even look like he trained
a day for that fight
he looked like he was a little bit out
of shape like a little
ring around the midsection and smiling
like smiling like he knew
what he was gonna do like how are you
gonna beat me he's so little
yeah like he's been fighting these big
power punchers and he's fighting this
little guy who's
known for his kicks right catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify watch back
catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience